Let's consider the motion
of a symmetric object that's
rotating about a fixed axis.
So we could take some object.
And we can imagine this is
sort of what sometimes people
refer to as a spinning top.
And it's rotating about
this symmetry axis, k.
And we know that the angular
velocity of the object we
can write as omega z k hat.
And the angular momentum
about this symmetry
axis we just showed that was
equal to the moment of inertia
about this axis times
the angular velocity.
And in particular, the magnitude
of the angular momentum--
I'll just write that
L about that axis
is i axis times the magnitude
of the angular velocity.
Now, we've seen separately
that the kinetic energy
about this axis,
which we'll call
the rotational kinetic energy,
was 1/2 times the moment
of inertia about that axis times
the angular velocity squared.
But here, we see that omega
squared is equal to L over i.
So if we substitute that
in, we get L squared about
that axis over i axis squared.
And so we have a nice expression
for the kinetic rotational
kinetic energy is L squared
about that axis over 2 moment
of inertia about that axis.
And this we can describe
is the kinetic energy
of a symmetric body
about a fixed axis.
It is nice to
notice the angular--
the linear analogy
to this, when we
wrote that the momentum
of an object was mv,
so the magnitude of the
momentum is just m times v.
And when we write kinetic
energy translation as 1/2 and v
squared, we can write that as
a translational kinetic energy
as p squared over 2m.
So once again, we see this nice
analogy for rotational motion
where we describe it in
terms of the angular momentum
and the moment of inertia.
And linear motion,
we describe in terms
of momentum and the mass.